save the dinosaurs from island that's  about to explode what could go wrong  having dinosaurs on an island there's a  certain containment to that what it  takes to get these dinosaurs off the  island that is now an entirely new story  this is the second film of a trilogy you  get nostalgia and also a new story at  the same time there's a scene that we  have with blue we're all surrounding her  that felt emotional did I cry I've never  cried once in my life not even when I  was a baby and I came out and they  slapped me and I was like don't hit me  it was a roller coaster so that we could  drop fast enough to hit zero G's and  float for a second a film like this was  made created to be seen not only on a  big screen he's seen with an audience  you experience that together  you